the Vatican is setting its sights on the
Olympics after launching its own track
and field team this month the roughly 60
athletes include priests and those who
work in the Vatican's museums and
pharmacy the team had its first race
yesterday morning and Seth Doane was
there to see them run they posed in
front of the starting line as many teams
would but being vatican Athletics and
with their captain a Monsignor they also
prayed they joined about eight thousand
runners outside Rome's Olympic Stadium
for Sunday's 10k lacing up a nun and
stretching a member of the Pope's army
so a little bit of rain here not ideal
Chetty Hulk is a swiss guard one of the
select young men from switzerland who
sworn to protect the pope they carry on
a 500 year tradition often standing
perfectly still while on guard so it's a
relief to go running yeah and as well
and some teammates demonstrated the
Vatican offers some rather spectacular
training grounds from Iran is a form of
Prayer sister Marie tio is from France
the Swiss Guard said that you were the
best on the team this unlikely team
blended right in with the thousands of
runners and while there were no medals
Sunday for Vatican athletics the race
was a milestone for CBS this morning
Seth Dome Rome it also serves as a good
windbreaker
who knew I loved that story